what are the three worst ways to start a
story I think one of them is not
identifying a main point of view or a
main character and I've have seen it
where you linger for 10 to 15 pages of
the setup before I even meet the main
character I think that's hard to pull
off not saying it's
impossible but um I think that's one
area where starting a story like without
really our introducing our main
character can be really fraught with
danger
um uh I think writing a you know action
a big two bigger action sequence in the
beginning you leave yourself nowhere to
go I know a lot of action movies do
start that way
um uh and I think also if I was to
identify another bad way to start a
story is with too many characters I see
that quite often is that it's very hard
for me to discern who the main character
is if in the first 10 pages you've
introduced 10 10 to 15 characters it's
like I don't know who I'm following
whose story is this becomes muddy so I
think that starting a story off with too
many characters who have too many things
to say especially minor characters can
be confusing and really takes us away
from okay who are we following and who
am I going to empathize with and join on
this journey um I think that's one way
you wouldn't want to start a story I
think another way is if it's a horror
movie starting it with some kind of
comic sequence not a good idea unless
it's a horror comedy so I think getting
the tone wrong or setting up the wrong
tone for your movie especially when
you're wanting it to be a Sci-Fi but in
the first 10 pages you don't introduce
any elements that would exist in a
Sci-Fi World um that's you wouldn't want
to start a movie that way um and
starting a movie that's too
talky uh too much dialogue in the
beginning of your movie doesn't allow an
effective setup of the tone or the world
quite often what do audiences want from
a main character and what do writers
often get wrong I don't know all the
audiences but I'll speak generally based
on what I know I think you know for
instance my
brother doesn't want to go to a movie
and
think he just doesn't want to he wants
to go and be entertained you he wants to
go on a rolicking fast and furious type
ride I think it depends on why you why
you go to a movie I go to a movie
because I'm I want to be scared that's
why I go to movies um and so I think
audiences are drawn to certain genres
sometimes most of the time um and I
think that there are certain tropes in
those genres that they want to see
um and I think sometimes
writers I'll give you an example of when
I was starting out when I was in when I
was in grad school I wrote two romantic
comedies before I realized I'm not very
funny and um and I don't know that world
and frankly I wouldn't see them so the
dean of the school at that time at
graduation came to me and he said okay
so your professors all have really good
things to say about you that you you're
you you know talented you just have no
idea who you are I'm like what does that
what does that mean I don't really know
what that means and he said well think
of it this way you go to a cinema Lex
and it has 18 theaters in it right each
one of those theaters has the best of
every
genre which one do you go and see I said
well horror Thriller he why why why are
you writing romantic
comedies when you wouldn't even go and
see them I don't understand I was like
well that's when I came up with the idea
that was the genre it best fit in he's
like but you wouldn't go and see that
genre which means you don't really want
to see what you're writing on the screen
you you wouldn't go and see it write
what you want to see on the
screen thus my horror Fascination came
out in full force and I started writing
that and developing that but I think you
have to understand who you are and what
you like to see not just what you like
to write or what you think the the
audience is looking for CU I guarantee
you by the time you finish the
screenplay they're already looking for
something else and you saw that in the
found footage craze right everyone
started doing found footage movies well
they selling cu no one wants to see that
anymore 5 minutes later it the industry
changes that quick so I think as a
writer you do have to write what you
love you write what you would go and see
you know I wouldn't go and see romantic
comedies necessarily so why am I writing
them and I think that was the best piece
of advice with regards to the question
you just asked that I could have got
what are common ways that a movie dies
marketing um these days it can be
marketing I
think there are a lot of factors here um
one and it's something I'm doing in my
new in the new company that I'm working
with uh is
that is there such a thing anymore as a
$12 million indie
film I don't think so I mean how do you
make that money back with the the state
of the theatrical Market you know um
it's possible um I've heard people say I
want make A-list Indie dramas with
A-list actors I'm like well first of all
that's a paradox because if there's an
A-list actor with a Indie drama they
want to do they're not coming to you
right they've already got their own um
and they don't need your money there are
several factors here one is
mismanagement of budgets and a
misunderstanding of your
audience um Jason Blum has become a a
superstar in the horror world one
because he's passionate about it and two
he developed a model around how to
create lowbudget horror and how to make
money from it um and I think that a
movie will die if you're talking
financially um a movie will die when the
budget is too big and outsized because
once you have a movie you've then got to
lob a whole bunch of marketing money on
top of it and no one sees any money
until all that comes back and Studios
will will put on sales fees and
distribution fees and all these things
that they want to recoup before any
investor will will get their money or
their Equity back so
financially um it ties back into what I
said about theatrical marketing teams if
there's no confidence in something even
if you go ahead and make it and division
heads in studios if they want to make a
movie they have their own budgets they
can go and make the movie they can green
light it without the head of the studio
and go and do it but if the theatrical
marketing team or a marketing team don't
have any confidence in the movie they
have budgets too so they're not going to
spend as much as they would have on
something
else gets very convoluted but I think
that the the main problem now for me is
that the mid-range budget is almost dead
because um us domestic Market is hard
you know can Brad Pit still sell a movie
in this in the cinemas in this country
canny I'd go to see it yeah
can they make their money back on that
or is he a bigger star in certain
International territories he probably is
right the movie star system has changed
a great deal and whether they can on
their own sell a movie in a theater uh
I'm skeptical that he
could um put Ryan goling and Margo
Robbie together in a Barbie movie no
problem at all um but I think that's
that's one of the things where you have
to look at you know is a movie dead or
not
um financially yes if you don't Market
it properly or if there's no confidence
if the budget is too high compared to
where you're going to release it you
know um release platforms are different
now a streamer will pay a certain amount
of money um for instance there was a mve
one movie called One Night in
Miami um and we were we were looking at
buying that for the studio um and we
offered a certain amount and then in the
11th Hour Amazon comes in and says we're
going to give you this amount and
there's just no way that we could have
competed with that so what makes a movie
valuable is what you can sell it for and
make it out of and that's not to say
that you make all of your money out of
the box office movies have lives after
the box office and some movies have very
very lucrative lives on streaming and
then pay-per-view so I think it's a
being aware of that and where it's going
to sell um and what your budget range is
and who's attached to your movie the
package itself that will tell whether a
movie is going to die or not and you
have to be able and that's the art isn't
it I mean you have to be able to tell
that upfront before you you bury all
this money in
it